[Música]
momento de irnos a repasar la actualidad
en una parte del mundo en directo a que
nos vamos a jerusalén para hablar de una
de las noticias de la semana de esa gira
del presidente de eeuu joe biden por
medio oriente desde israel hasta arabia
saudita pasando por cisjordania por eso
conectamos con jerusalén en donde se
encuentra nuestro corresponsal federico
que barberena quien ha hecho el
seguimiento del mandatario
norteamericano efe de cómo se interpreta
el paso de vaivén en israel y los
territorios palestinos teniendo en
cuenta las difíciles relaciones entre
ambas partes
la visita de joe vayan a israel y los
territorios de palestino estuvo marcadas
diferencias en trato y en resultados
empezando por la duración mientras pasó
un día y medio en israel alternando
eventos o de políticos y sociales a los
palestinos les dedicó la mañana de este
viernes el mandatario estadounidense
dejó un mensaje claro para los israelíes
está comprometido con su seguridad y con
evitar que irán desarrolle armas
nucleares la vía diplomática de su
opción 1 pero no descarto la acción
militar como último recurso también
profundizó esta nueva línea que pretende
para medio oriente con más integración
de israel y cooperación con países
árabes de ahí su mediación con la larga
saudita que cosechó como primer fruto la
apertura del espacio aéreo saudita a los
vuelos desde y hacia israel
esta política estadounidense está
aislando cada vez más a los palestinos
bailén intentó compensar reiterando su
apoyo a una solución de dos estados que
no ve posible en un futuro cercano y sin
hacer mención a la ocupación israelí a
falta de paz ayudas adicionales de 200
millones de dólares para la agencia de
la onu dedicada a refugiados palestinos
y 100 para los hospital de jerusalén
este además será renovada promesa de
mejorar la red de internet móvil en los
territorios palestinos también por
primera vez se resaltó la figura de la
periodista palestino estadounidense de
shinawatra asesinada durante una redada
israelí en yenín en machos pasado gusto
a pocos para los palestinos que
recibieron la visita con escepticismo y
lo hicieron notar en carteles
denunciando lo que califican de
apartheid de israel y pidiendo justicia
por sir in mensaje que también llevaron
manifestantes durante la visita de biden
a un hospital en jerusalén este esto fue
un hito porque un presidente
estadounidense nunca había visitado un
barrio mayormente palestino fuera de la
ciudad vieja
que de otra parte biden ya comenzó su
agenda en arabia saudita con muchas
críticas porque el presidente había
hecho una campaña en campaña hizo un
llamado a aislar a este país por el
crimen del periodista llama al hayyi que
esperar de esta última parada por medio
oriente
la falta de detalles sobre las reuniones
el primer gesto de bailén en su llegada
a arabia saudita es lo más comentado
optó por saludar con un choque de puños
al príncipe mohammed bin salman pero si
estrechó la mano del rey salman bin
abdulaziz cada movimiento es observado
con lupa por las críticas este viaje al
reino al que biden prometió tratar de
parias debido a la acusación de la cia
de que el príncipe saudita estuvo detrás
del asesinato del periodista llaman ja
sóc si en 2018
de ahí que era casablanca subrayará que
byd en viaja para recalibrar las
relaciones con su histórico aliado al
que al margen de los derechos humanos se
necesita pedirle apoyo para bajar los
precios del petróleo que han empujado la
inflación en un foro con otros líderes
del golfo bailén solicitará aumentar la
producción de crudo para reducir los
precios aunque no se esperan medidas
inmediatas al respecto también bailén
quiere marcar presencia para evitar un
vacío que puedan llenar países como
china rusia o irán y sobre este último
pretende resaltar la importancia de
crear una alianza de seguridad regional
incluyendo a israel una posibilidad de
la que por ejemplo se hace bajo irak